abbas bayat y est ton avis moi je le
crois je fais documentaire les autres
ils sont riches peuvent leur fauteuil
son jeu sans riches la grande histoire
et nos petites histoires personnelles se
sont retrouvés intimement liés
ça fait 20 ans qui a des docks sur lcp
ça représente plus de 1500 documentaire
en 20 ans 250 doc inédit qu'on a vu que
sur lcp
[Musique]
on est une jolie lucarne à 20h30 pour
des films qui passerait peut-être à
00h30 ou une heure du matin ailleurs mon
chirac c'est pas un personnage ordinaire
celle qu'a fait le plus d'audience
c'était mon chirac
peut-être aussi parce que justement
s'attendait pas à voir jean louis debré
documentaries je sais pas qui soit
vraiment le documentaire c'est un miroir
du monde dans lequel on est ça fait écho
finalement à toutes les thématiques les
sujets qui sont discutées traité dans
l'assemblée les parrains et ils ont
guidé la nourriture passe avant tout ce
qui est logique
ils disent toujours à la fin du mois tu
préfère manger des jouets ou du steak
je suis je réponds du stic récemment kim
un peu parce que j'ai des fois j'ai
envie de jouer ça avait suscité une
telle émotion
il ya eu un tel écho dans les
téléspectateurs qui ont été assaillis de
paquets de jouer à l'accueil de lcp
photographe
c'est du grec c'est celui qui écrit avec
la lumière
abbas bayat bassin c'est l'histoire d'un
photographe franco iranien ces photos
vous avez certainement tous deux en noir
et blanc magnifique de l'apartheid à la
révolution iranienne
j'ai tellement près de lui là j'étais
obligé de reculer comme ça pour pouvoir
le photographier le cadre et que je
crois que la photo parle d'elle même
voilà et c'est le seul film là qui nous
a été acheté par la bbc
donc là aussi grande fierté ça va mieux
quand on le bouchon c'est plus juste une
petite chaîne parmi tant d'autres comme
on pouvait l'être il ya vingt ans c'est
vrai qu'on a aussi grandi on s'est
affirmée on est devenu une belle chaîne
et ça attire et ça donne envie à des
documentaristes de grands noms des
signatures comme william karel de faire
un film que pour lcp
on sert le budget on va peut-être pas
faire une marche de dingue on va faire
un film qui va exister qu il va avoir
une belle exposition c'est ça qui est
génial lcpc que la passion l' envie de
faire ce film de raconter cette histoire
sa balle et tout donc c'est vrai que
c'est rare
[Musique]